Rose to power in Russia from humble
beginnings in Saint Petersburg after
being jailed for nine years for robbery
and fraud he became a hot dog salesman
and then the man known as Putin's Chef
his catering company hosted events for
foreign leaders as well as President
Vladimir Putin's private birthday
parties it wasn't until 2022 the
pregosian admitted that he had founded
the Wagner private military company
eight years earlier in eastern Ukraine
he'd previously denied all connections
to the mercenary group and sued anyone
linking him to Wagner
mercenaries are illegal in Russia but
pregosian's close links to Putin and
Russia's Elite allowed him to bypass
legislation and gave plausible
deniability of any involvement in
operations overseas
as well as Ukraine the Wagner group has
been linked to military operations in
Syria since 2015 and aiding governments
combat Rebel groups in the Central
African Republic Libya Mali and Sudan
pregosian is also linked with exerting
military and political influence in Chad
Mozambique and Zimbabwe the Wagner has
been so successful as a private military
company that it has become essentially a
franchise and so you have different uh
really very distinct organizations that
carry the same brand
Wagner was an important force in
Russia's invasion of Ukraine including
the assaults on solidar and buckmut
pragosan commanded up to 50 000 troops
in Ukraine mostly recruited from Russian
prisons in exchange for a pardon
he underlined his mercenaries victories
while playing down the role of the
Russian army
obviously Putin has created
isn't a self-made man
he is Putin's project to create a sort
of a competitive alternative military
force in Russia to boost the
effectiveness of the regular Russian
army this later turned into open
criticism where pregojan didn't mince
his words in attacking defense minister
Sergey shigu and Chief of Staff Valerie
grasimov for undersupplying his troops
we have a 70 shortage of ammunition
where's the ammunition look at them fake
when bakmut was seized in May 2023 after
more than six months of fighting
pregosian and his men took a passive
role and the Kremlin began to reign in
Wagner demanding the group register and
Report directly to the Army pregosian
refused and his confrontation with
Russia's military leadership reached the
boiling point on June 23rd when he was
accused of armed Mutiny and treason
Dimitri met vedenko Al Jazeera